[Music]
hi I'm Kate Kirkpatrick I'm a lecturer
in philosophy religion and culture at
King's College London and my primary
areas of research are the philosophy
religion and existentialism and I'm
especially interested in the
intersection of religious questions with
the philosophical questions that were
being debated in French philosophy in
the second quarter of the 20th century
what does Beauvoir teach us what is the
void teach us quite a lot I think the
most important theme that runs
throughout her works is that becoming an
ethical self involves having the kind of
right balance between prioritizing the
needs of others and recognizing a
certain kind of one's own needs as an
important aspect of that we're to have
theories sit in relation to her
existentialist contemporaries so there
are many things that Babar shares with
her existentialist contemporaries and
partly as a feature of having learned
philosophy in France and the syllabus
for the aggregation in philosophy in the
period in which Beauvoir was learning
was something that everyone had to learn
together so she shares certain concerns
with the concept of freedom no this is
something we see in her earliest
surviving notebooks and so she's she's
wrestling with the questions of what it
means to be free and to value one's
freedom but also to value the freedoms
of others um so I mean one of the things
that makes Beauvoir's philosophies so
interesting is that it's constantly in
conversation with her contemporaries and
with philosophers of the past and it's
when this is one of the things also that
shaped her reception as honestly in
Sartre shadow philosophically because
she wasn't translated into English
and when she was translated into English
she was often only translated partially
or without the philosophical rigor that
was in the original French text really
so when did full translations of her
work come coming in into English well
full translations are not yet available
and so the there's been a great
scholarly effort it through the Beauvoir
research series which is published by
the university of illinois press over
the last couple of decades and there's
so but even the second sex which is the
book that she's most famous for was
translated without a very philosophical
approach and published in 1953 and that
translation shaped the reception of
Beauvoir in the english-speaking world
until 2009 when a new translation
appeared the first one actually only
included about 85% of the original
French text it excluded her discussion
of housework it excluded a lot of
discussions of how women in their own
voice so it was it was whatever the
intentions of the translator the message
of the book was quite altered by the
translation that had at first in English
and even in french-speaking countries
with French texts there was presumably
still this presumption that Beauvoir
relied on Sartre oh like that that she
was shaped by her partner in infrasonic
lis yes no I wouldn't deny that she was
shaped by her partner philosophically
but I think the problem is that the that
kind of admission usually only goes one
way and sart's philosophy was very much
shaped by her commitments and her
questions and her challenges to what he
published but the problem is that
because Beauvoir wasn't translated until
much later what came into english was a
lot of sart's philosophy and her
contributions to the french
existentialism were widely overlooked
especially in the popular sphere do you
think time lags like that which have a
big impact on public perception are gone
now in a digital age do you think that
could happen
again well I haven't yet seen a couple
that has a contender for sergeant
Beauvoir and as public intellectuals in
but I think translation is still very
difficult to achieve and it's it seems
to be the case that it's fewer women are
translated than men and so I think you
know the times have changed but I'm not
convinced that they've changed as much
as they need to we're spreading women's
work or intellectual work is
acknowledged as it should be so okay
so why decide to write about Beauvoir's
life rather than about her writing so
the decision to write about her life was
not an easy one to make but one of ours
points in the second sex is that women
are often judged as successes or
failures on the basis of their romantic
life they're often reduced to their
romantic lives and what what I have
found partly through my research on
Sarge because I worked on sari before
Beauvoir was that there were a lot of
French philosophical sources informing
his early philosophy that English
speakers didn't know about and so they
didn't can hear the conversations that
he was having with the French
philosophical tradition in texts like
being nothingness and when I read both
of our student Diaries which cover the
period from 1926 to 1930 which
importantly includes a few years before
sight was even in the picture I found
that she was preoccupied by themes that
would later be called existentialist
before she even met him and that they
were reading many of the same neglected
sources and so the idea that these ideas
were his in the first place was
problematic and once I started to look
at the way both were described their
relationship in the different volumes of
her autobiography which was published
over twelve years between 1958 and 1972
um I saw that she had noticed the way
her successes were attributed to Sarge
so she was called Sark's disciple she
was accused of popularizing his ideas
she didn't live to see the obituary that
called her as imagination list as her
inkwell but she lived to see a lot of
reviews of her books where the content
of her novels or her philosophical works
were attributed to Sartre and she was
just called effectively a good
communicator that's what women are good
at communicating not thinking they just
know how to when someone else has done
the thinking to communicate it well so
once I saw that pattern emerge in the
reception of her works I became
extremely suspicious of a lot of the
existing scholarly literature about
Beauvoir in English and I thought what
happens if we read the rest of her life
on the basis of the philosophy that she
was developing as a young woman and I
found that there's a lot of continuity
there and that um you started has been
given way more credit than he deserves
yeah and so speaking maybe a bit more
about her philosophy what might Beauvoir
say about contemporary discourses
surrounding issues like gender identity
and biological essentialism yes so she
clearly rejects biological essentialism
but that term has taken on many meanings
in the contemporary context which were
not necessarily present in the same
senses in 1949 and one of the one of the
interesting things about the second sex
now is that many people think on the
basis of its most famous sentence where
before says that when is born oh sorry
one is not born but rather becomes a
woman that she's denying the relevance
of Anatomy to what it means to be a
woman but that sentence actually is a
almost verbatim quotation from a French
philosopher who wrote about the freedom
and determinism debate and then the late
1890s called Alfred who a
and he said that one is not born but
rather becomes free and bovar was an
existentialist philosopher who was
committed to the idea that freedom is
something that you constantly have to
strive for in your life and the she
thought that women were not encouraged
to pursue their own values and to pursue
their own freedom in the same ways that
men were as a as a result of childhood
so she says in the second sex what she's
trying to investigate is what humanity
has made of the human female and she
thinks that culture and childhood play a
really important role in the oppression
of women and even the feelings of
division and dissatisfaction that women
have within themselves and how about
then existentialism and feminism are
they compatible yes but what is
existentialism is very much compatible
with her feminism and I think one of the
things that I find fascinating as a
philosopher is how she didn't know she
did not write the second sex as an
activist book so there's a 1975
interview where Beauvoir says she wrote
it as a theorem theoretical work and she
was surprised by the activist role that
went on to play there's a lot of
philosophical work happening in this in
the second sex but but one of the things
that I think is so interesting is that
she's looking at the challenges that
existentialist in general are concerned
with about how you become a self how you
become an ethical self and she's saying
there are challenges confronting women
in becoming ethical cells which are not
identical to the challenges confronting
men and so I think they're compatible
and part of the work of the second sex
is to show how okay cool and I think
it's probably implicit but um how well
'van is she and her philosophy today
so I mean I have been this this my
biography of Babar has been out for a
month tomorrow and I had been astonished
by the the number of people who have
said to me how much it spoke into the
present situation so I think there are
strong progress narratives in feminism
and a tendency to think that women of a
generation before or two generations
before are no longer relevant
but there are some questions in human
life like how to love ethically and what
it means to become yourself given
certain constraints that just don't date
and I think Beauvoir is a philosopher
who spoke to those
you